es hora de ampliar la información
económica de esta jornada por ello me
acompaña en el estudio nuestra
periodista daniela blandón daniela
buenas noches bienvenida iniciamos en
argentina porque el gobierno anunció que
suspende las exportaciones de carne así
es valentina buenas noches las otras la
suspensión estará vigente durante 30
días como una medida contra el aumento
de los precios en el mercado interno
pues en efecto mientras la inflación
aumentó el 46 por ciento en los 12 meses
que terminaron en abril el precio de la
carne se disparó en más del 65 por
ciento pero como este país es el cuarto
exportador mundial de carne vacuna estas
ventas son muy importantes y uno de los
motores de la economía y es por esa
razón que los productores convocaron a
un paro desde la medianoche del jueves y
hasta el 28 de mayo para mostrar su
rechazo escuchemos
es una medida que a nadie le gusta y
mucho menos sea nosotros como sector
productivo pero creemos que el camino y
las decisiones que está tomando el poder
ejecutivo son profundamente cerradas
daniela pues una decisión bastante
controversial vamos ahora a chile que
descartó los impuestos a los llamados
súper ricos
valentina la propuesta de establecer un
impuesto a los súper ricos como ya lo
hicieron chile como ya lo hicieron
argentina y bolivia fue rechazada este
martes por la cámara de diputados la
norma iba dirigida a quienes amasarán
una fortuna de más de 22 millones de
dólares lo que sí fue aprobado y
despachado al senado dentro del mismo
proyecto fue la reducción del iva que
hoy desde el es del 19% hasta 2022 para
algunos bienes y servicios y se los voy
a enumerar si el senado lo aprueba
quedarían pagando el 10 por ciento los
servicios ofrecidos por empresas
funerarias algunos alimentos productos
sanitarios hostelería restaurante y
asistencia dental
y otros y bajaría el 4% de este iva para
alimentos como pan harina huevos y leche
y productos como libros diarios y
revistas medicamentos prótesis e
implantes entre otros le dejo este dato
para que lo piense valentina chile es el
tercer país con más multimillonarios de
latinoamerica y según cifras de la
revista forbes las 8 mayores fortunas
del país incluida la del presidente
sebastián piñera crecieron en conjunto
un 73% del año pasado justamente
hablábamos hace poco de la concentración
de la riqueza que hay en hitler
ahora cambiamos de tema un grupo de
países le urge a la organización mundial
del comercio que inicie el debate sobre
la levanta miento de las patentes de las
vacunas contra el coes 19 usted
recordará valentina que el presidente de
eeuu joe biden
mostró su apoyo a la propuesta de que
liberen estas patentes para darle más
velocidad a la vacunación contra el kobe
19 esto le valió un buen disgusto con
las farmacéuticas
han pasado más de dos semanas desde esto
y las discusiones ni siquiera han
comenzado de los 164 miembros de la
organización mundial del comercio
62 partidarios de la propuesta enviaron
hoy una carta pidiendo que las
negociaciones comiencen lo antes posible
india y sudáfrica veamos son los
promotores de la extensión junto con
algunos países asiáticos otros africanos
y del lado latinoamericano están bolivia
y venezuela a la unión europea no le ha
agradado mucho la idea aunque coinciden
que deben encontrar maneras de agilizar
la vacunación y otros como reino unido
suiza y japón también tienen dudas sobre
si la liberación de patentes es la
solución lo cierto es que las decisiones
en lado de meses se toman por consenso
así que el voto negativo de uno solo
puede tumbar la propuesta
daniela y finalizó la cumbre de países
africanos liderada por francia el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón
recibió a los líderes africanos y jefes
de prestamistas multilaterales en esta
cumbre destinada a encontrar salidas a
la crisis una de las consecuencias o de
las conclusiones fue que el mandatario
hizo un llamado para que él
monetariointernacional reasigne 100.000
millones de dólares de los llamados
derechos especiales de giro a países
africanos estos derechos son recursos
que normalmente están disponibles para
los países desarrollados y lo que buscan
es redirigir los daniela y vamos con los
indicadores económicos de la jornada
valentina wall street del cerró en rojo
marcado por las caídas en el sector
tecnológico las acciones europeas
subieron alemania cerró casi igual pero
llegó a alcanzar un nuevo máximo
histórico y las acciones de américa
latina cerraron sin mucho movimiento y
por último la cifra del día 0,3 por
ciento que creció el producto interno
bruto de chile interanual en el primer
trimestre de 2021 en plena segunda ola
de pandemia valentina daniela gracias
por la información a ustedes gracias por
su sintonía continúen con nosotros en
france 24